[Music]
teenage climate activist greta thunder
joining a protest in london on friday
demonstrators targeted london's
financial district to call for an end in
fossil fuel investment it comes as a
climate summit kicks off in scotland
tomorrow where world leaders will try to
keep global warming in check
coal made up nearly a third of
planet-warming carbon emissions in 2018
and critics say countries need to cast
it aside at a much faster rate
but in the uk where coal was once king
its use has been plummeting
from northern england roxanna seberry
shows us how it's being done
this used to be the uk's biggest power
plant fueled by coal
now it's one of the last
there's very little coal left here now
jason chipstone a manager at drax says
the plant will stop using coal to
produce electricity next year
two years after that the entire country
is set to follow is this the future of
power yeah we believe so drax has been
transitioning to a different kind of
fuel transported by train here to
northern england would
around 15 of these trains arrive here
each day each one carries enough wood
pellets to power around 800 homes for
one year
we take sawdust as residues from things
like saw mills so all of the other bits
of the tree that people don't generally
want coal is relatively simple to store
you can leave it outside here for years
but biomass has to be kept dry and at
controlled temperatures so drax built
these massive storage domes they stretch
over 200 feet tall and together they
hold over three hundred thousand tons of
wood pellets
biomass now generates around eight
percent of the country's power drax says
it's much cleaner than coal
we believe it's completely
environmentally friendly it's a part of
the energy transition that we have to go
through we just don't know what the real
emissions are energy analyst phil
mcdonald says a switch to large-scale
wood burning isn't necessarily better
than burning coal it's reducing the the
carbon stored in forests and it's also
having all these knock-on biodiversity
impacts we have an alternative which is
very low risk which is using wind and
solar the uk is moving in that direction
coupled with closing down coal plants
the country has cut its carbon emissions
faster than any other major economy in
the past decade
renewable energy is getting cheaper
while the government charges big
polluters a high price for carbon
emissions
how big a deal is this for this country
i think it is a big a big deal because
the industrial revolution began here and
and it was built on on the back of coal
[Music]
coal powered homes trains and factories
helping britain expand its empire
london was enveloped in a 40-mile belt
of fog
but in 1952 the country's coal addiction
spewed smog so thick and toxic in london
it killed thousands the crisis convinced
the country to look for cleaner forms of
fuel can other countries do the same
thing
yeah when we look at places like china
or india that still have a lot of coal
on the system the switch to fully clean
power can happen very quickly
even in the u.s coal plants are shutting
down but it's far too early to count
coal out globally coal use is rebounding
this year and environmentalists are
calling on several countries to ditch
this dirtiest of fossil fuels faster
back at drax jenny stanley says she's
proof that new jobs can be created in
the process
how important is this plant to the
communities around here it's the main
focus really so you've this is i see
this from my bedroom window
the company trained the 25 year old as a
civil engineer who now helps in their
biomass operation as small as it is my
job maybe as small as it is right now it
could be a knock-on effect to ensure
that we
reach that goal of ensuring our planet
sustains and survives
she hopes britain will inspire other
countries to kick their coal habits a
goal that grows more urgent by the day
for cbs saturday morning roxanna seberry
selby england
and it makes a difference i remember
going to london in the 80s and it being
a gray city going there in the 90s and
it was just sunny skies everywhere it's
amazing but the two things you think
about the jobs that how do you replace
those for those who are in the coal
industry and then maybe the one way you
do do some of this is those high price
tags on the carbon emissions you force
incentives of
these businesses and the other issues
involved here in burning the wood
pellets which
people may not have thought about before
right no easy solution there is no easy
solution that is exactly right but at
least they are facing facts